john mcguinness here with the game spot
news update amidst an outcry from
consumers sony has reversed its
controversial driveclub upgrade policy
here's what happened sony announced that
PlayStation Plus subscribers will be
able to download a free but limited
version of driveclub with only 10 cars
and 11 tracks roughly one-fifth of
what's in the full game anyone with the
PS Plus edition can upgrade to the full
version for fifty dollars ten dollars
off the retail cost however there was a
catch if your PlayStation Plus account
expired you would lose access to the
upgraded content and would presumably
have to buy the full game again just to
play it after a couple days of fan rage
sony has reversed that decision with a
statement that reads PlayStation
recognizes that the prior plan for
driveclub entitlement for the upgrade to
the PS Plus edition was not appropriate
now if you intend on downloading
driveclub PlayStation Plus edition and
upgrading to the full game experience
you will have access to the full game
even if your PlayStation Plus
subscription runs out pink sony
driveclub launches october 7th
exclusively for the PlayStation 4 we'll
have full coverage here on gamespot com
you